how important is it to respond to
comments in terms of building your
website whether it's just in the thread
underneath each article or also via
social media yeah you know I think about
it more from the perspective of
community engagement and right now on
new film school it's comments on blog
posts going forward it's gonna be much
more of a community where people can
talk to each other and post their own
things and and you know I think for a
blog it's very important because you are
not just it's not you know we'd like to
think about it I know a film school as
it's not a lecture it's not a professor
up in front of a blackboard talking to
all the students it's you know a class
where there's a circle and we're one of
the maybe we're a moderator or something
but everyone is basically talking to
each other so I think it's very
important just how you think about the
community whether that be Commons or
whether that be social media and I think
you know we've done and we do a good job
of responding the comments I think but
as far as the the social media aspects
and other things that we could be doing
we just haven't been able to do what I
would like to do because it's a you know
right now it's essentially just a blog
but that's gonna be changing and I think
the most valuable thing you can have as
a website is a community that you know
is passionate and comes back regularly
and you know finds value in the site
that they're participating in whether
that be in comments or some other sort
of interaction do you remember going
back to when you got your first comment
your first interaction from someone
reading and and how was that and how
diligent were you in responding yeah I
think it's one of the hardest things
about starting a website from scratch is
feeling like you're you know putting
stuff out there and no one's reading it
and of course I'm sure you guys have
seen as well that you could have a
thousand people read an article and not
have a sink
or many more than thousand so it's very
discouraging at the beginning and I
don't remember what the first comment
was but I do remember years later
feeling like well no one can really say
anything to me now that is gonna
surprise me because by the time I
brought on other writers to the site I
had written a thousand posts and there
are twenty thousand comments on the site
so I felt like it's you know getting
comments is a very good skin thickening
procedure where you have to believe in
yourself and you have to sort of stick
to your guns and at the same time it's
great to listen and you hear a lot of
different perspectives on your work and
what you're doing but I actually should
go back and look at what the first
comment was cuz I know for a fact that
he could go back to the very first post
on my site in 2005 where I say hey I'm
an unemployed kid in North Carolina I'm
not gonna film school but I don't know
where this film career is going let's
find out to this day there are still
zero comments on that post so I have to
go back and look and see which which one
actually somebody said something I'm
sure it's just a friend of mine saying
you know hey Ryan you suck or something
but you know I'll go friend that
wouldn't put it on the wall do you
remember when you finally launched no
film school on Twitter or Facebook was
that simultaneous with oh we were late
yeah I was late to Twitter you know we
haven't been great about our social
media presence and we need to improve at
that a lot but it's just one of those
things where there are only so many
hours in the day and we've really
focused on creating content sharing
content and you know hopefully will
become more of a social media presence
going forward well obviously two million
hits a month you're doing something
right so maybe the thing you're doing
right is staying off social I mean I see
so many people on social media and I've
had to pull back myself that it's just
it's like is this really
I mean I hate to say this but sometimes
it's like a giant circle jerk mm-hm just
gonna say it and and sorry if I offend
anyone but that's what it is sometimes I
think that maybe you're on the right
path if you're focusing more on content
and responding to things on the website
rather than just like Tooting your own
horn on mm-hmm I think there are a
couple of challenges with social media
on the Twitter side it's very ephemeral
you know things drift off people's front
pages in a matter of seconds and on
Facebook I think the challenge is that
you don't really own your audience or
your data and progressively more and
more Facebook wants to charge you to be
able to reach the audience that has
already given you permission to reach
them you know they like you and then
you're like well now you like me I have
to pay money for me to say hey here's
this thing so you know for me the thing
that I really focused on instead of
social media was email because I knew
that I would own that and that you know
email is stickier than a Twitter post
you send somebody an email it stays in
their inbox they have to delete it or
unsubscribe or read it and so that was
really my focus because I felt like it
wasn't trendy it wasn't something that
was gonna come and go and and you know
I'm sure someday there will be something
better than the email I don't know if
it's the new Google Hangouts or what you
know google tried wave and all these
different things but that's been the
thing that I focused on except felt like
it was more evergreen it wasn't
something that was gonna come and go and
die off and but I do think if there's a
lot to be said for social media and we
just we don't have a social media person
and we don't have enough time to make it
more interactive for now
you